good
[Music]
hello how are you greetings to him and
jaramillo with his report of the day today
monday december 14 the first shipment of
vaccines is about to arrive in southern nevada
some of the doses will be stored in
the university medical center and
wang yes  the vaccines will be stored in
these refrigerators the distribution of
the vaccines will be in three phases and the
people scheduled to receive the
vaccine are workers in the
health sector as well as the
most vulnerable people the second phase
will include people at high risk and
these could  start receiving them
as early as January the vaccine will be
available to all state residents
in the spring the
state governor also announced that he will sign a
new moratorium to prevent
tenants impacted by the pandemic from
being evicted from their homes
the help he is currently providing
to the center for disease control is
due December 31 and some 30-40
million  of people could lose their
homes if
the moratorium for the state of nevada
is not extended will be activated tomorrow December 15
until March 31, 2021 and the
state pause activated three weeks ago will be
extended until January 15 the
governor of the state of  nevada
sipse psoe informed residents that the
restrictions will remain in place
until the middle of the first of next
year
these include a
25% limited capacity in restaurants and casinos
private gatherings at home should be
limited to only 10 people from no
more than two households and gatherings  Public
houses are limited to 50 people or 25 percent of the allowed capacity, whichever is less, and the
Diana Motown Animal Shelter wants to
remind the public that if you are looking to
give your family a pet this
Christmas to please consider adopting
the shelter now.  is offering
free adoptions for adult cats and
dogs 30 pounds or larger to
view  all the animals available for
you can visit the shelter page or
call to make an appointment and meet the
future member of your family for more
information visit the
univision.com page and now we go with your
weather forecast temperatures are expected to be
close to normal  there will be a
bit of clouds and breezes this week
today's high rolling 58 degrees
have a good day I'm this light mine and
this was the 15th in Spanish
[Music]